ah c'est pas les profits c'est sûr mais
moi je vous le redis je suis un vrai
amoureux des animaux je suis contre la
maltraitance quand j'entends brigitte
bardot qui s'est battu pour les bébés
phoques
je vous embrasse brigitte vous avez
complètement raison j'aime certainement
les animaux autant que vous quand
j'entends une corinne touzet qui
s'étaient battus pour les pauvres chiens
les professeurs ont transformé en
manteau je sais plus trop je suis
complètement avec vous quand j'entends
la en chine l'effet de yulin vous
ébouillanté vivant des les chiens comme
banjoïste outils pour avoir la chair
plus fraîches et c'est scandaleux
quand j'entends cette maltraitance je
suis quelqu'un qui suit pour le
bien-être de l'animal vient parfaire la
maltraiter ya des gens qui sont au lion
mâle prenez leur leurs animaux et donnez
les nous à nous professionnels qui
connaissons on s'en occupera
nous dans des éventuels structuré
sanctuaire que si je rajoute chez nous
mais les mettez pas dans les mains des
pro d animal ils vont nous les tuer on
en interne à la ramasse que tu vas
chercher à boire ou pas le président de
république
on est en train de voir pour lui faire
une aide mais je pense à le meilleur des
courriers monsieur le président c'est
maintenant je vous le dis en direct
repasser les images je peux vous
rencontrer venez voir à pain der land
vous êtes un homme de terrain j'ai vu
que vous étiez à nice pour aider tous
ces pauvres gens j'accepte le moins
perdu leur maison dans les petits
cirques dans les grands cirques
venez avec moi et vous allez voir les
conditions de vie et qu'on est en train
de faire une passe et une injustice pour
les animaux dans un premier temps les
animaux de cirque pour les familles de
cirque les familles de gens de petits
cirques on est en train de faire une
injustice ou vous allez tuer tout le
monde